We're about to begin another programming practice gem.
This is optional material for students who would like to gain a little more practice
programming and debugging.
And what happens here will not influence your grade in any way.
Today's problem: Given a list--could be empty, could be arbitrarily long--
print all sublists of that list.
I'll give an example of what this means in just a second.
If you prefer a more math-y explanation,
for us this is the same problem as given a set, print all the subsets.
For example, suppose the input is the 3-element list containing the strings LM,
ECS, and SBA.
Then we want the output to include the empty list--we don't have any of them--
all of the lists containing just 1 of them,
all of the lists containing any pair of them, and then all of them.
And one way to think about this is that you are throwing a party
or perhaps hosting a dinner and you've invited your 3 friends: LM, ECS, and SBA.
Who could show up?
One possibility is that no one shows up and you eat alone. That would be super sad.
Another possibility is that only your first friend shows up or only the second
or only the third, and then you have a dinner for 2.
It could be that any pair of them show up, you have a great time,
or it could be that everyone shows up and everything works out just as you'd hoped.
So you can think of this as a guest list for a party
and you want to know what are all of the possible combinations
of people who could actually attend.
In this particular example, we started with 3 friends
and ended up with 8 possibilities--1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Totally optional quiz that does not count for your grade:
If the input list had 5 entries, if you invited 5 friends to your dinner party,
how many possible subsets or arrangements,
ranging from no one shows up to everyone shows up, would there be?
Fill in the blank.